define a good word is a sequence of
letters that content that consists only
of the letters a B and C some of these
letters may not appear in the sequence
and in which a is never immediately
followed by B B is never immediately
followed by C and C is never immediately
followed by a how many seven letter good
words are there so let's just think
about this a little bit so there's
letters with just a is B's and C's and
then it could be all A's all B's all C's
so that's up because some letters might
not appear and a is never immediately
followed by B so a can only be followed
by another a or another C B is never
immediately followed by C which means
that B can only be followed by an A or
another B and C is never immediately
followed by a so C can only be followed
by another C or a B so how many seven
letter good words are there so let's
just think about the places we have
seven letters so one two three four five
six seven letters now there's no
constraints on this first letter since
it's not following anything so it could
be an a B or a C so there's three
there's three possibilities for this
first letter now there's three
possibilities for this first letter but
no matter what pot what no matter what
letter this is how many possibilities
are there for this second letter over
here well if this was an A you could the
second letter could only be an A or a C
because it can't be followed by B if
this was a B it could own the second
letter could only be a B or an A because
it can't be followed by a see if this
was a C the second letter could only be
a B or C so no matter what letter this
first letter is the second letter can
only have two possibilities there could
only be two possibilities or another way
to think about it is there's one letter
no matter what letter this is there's
one letter that's being ruled out here
so it can only be two possibilities well
the same thing is here we're going to
stick some letter here and no matter
what letter there is over here it's
going to rule out one possibility over
here so we're going to have
only two possible letters that we can
put here no matter what letter is there
and use the same logic only two
possibilities there only two
possibilities there only two
possibilities there and then only two
possibilities there so how many total
possibilities do we have well 3 times 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 this is
1 2 3 4 5 6 2's so this is equal to 3
times 2 to the 6th power
which is 3 times 2 to the 2 to the 6th
is 32 times 2 is 64 which is equal to
180 plus 12 is equal to 192 there's 192
possible good 7 letter
good words or good words is defined
above